in a year of huge hardcore blockbuster
games you'd be forgiven for thinking
about the Wii U and letting out a little
scoff but the Wii U has given us some of
this year's best video game surprises
games which have appeased hardcore
devotees and turned skeptical heads at
the same time captain toad treasure
tracker was released after the close of
our 2014 Game of the Year awards which
makes it eligible for honors this year
plus it was released in European and
oceanic regions in 2015 taking the
enjoyable captain toad stages from Super
Mario 3d World and expanding them to
create large rich puzzle worlds has been
despite early fears a wonderful success
the undeniably adorable toad and
toadette are a key part of the games
appeal of course but so are the
increasingly clever and challenging
puzzles design ideas that flourish both
from and within treasure trackers
mechanical simplicity
the first times latrine was revealed we
were surprised Nintendo was creating a
post-apocalyptic third-person team based
online multiplayer shooter when it was
released we were surprised it was so
damn fun to play putting the focus on
mobility and controlling territory
splatoon involves controlling half kid
half squid characters and painting
arenas in your team's color having turf
in your favor
allows significant tactical advantages
the most enjoyable of which is the
ability to swim around in squid form at
speed filled with bright colors and
upbeat Japanese rock soundtrack and
fashionable accessories for your
character splatoon is a shooter with an
overwhelmingly positive feel and with
the game steady stream of free
post-release content those feelings have
lasted all year when it comes to post
release content though Super Mario maker
is king the creation tool allows you to
design 2d platformer levels using the
tool sets of the iconic Meyer brothers
games which hold fond memories for so
many videogame lovers the level maker is
both efficiently intuitive and charming
making it a joy to use for building and
sharing stages with the wider community
but even if making levels is unappealing
to you Mario maker also acts as an
extremely valuable portal to an infinite
bounty of unique platformer creations
from simple but surprising stages to
sadistic jaw-dropping görlitz Super
Mario maker and its bustling community
ensure there's always something new and
special waiting each time you turn on
the console
there's no denying that the WiiU
attracts a slightly younger audience and
so do toys to life games this year lego
dimensions
entered the scene bringing with it a
host of iconic pop culture characters
and causing the wilds of parents and
members of various fandoms to tremble
anxiously characters from Back to the
Future portal to Doctor Who Ghostbusters
the DC Comics universe and more not only
got physical lego sets that were fully
realized and voiced in-game and could
interact with their unlikely allies Lego
dimensions bridges the gap between
different entertainment franchises
between toy and game between young and
old and it succeeds on all those fronts
but in a year of hardcore blockbuster
game 2015 you should think of the Wii U
because Xenoblade Chronicles X exists
and it's sci-fi open-world is enormous
and filled with great experiences
Xenoblade is not a game for the
impatient it's filled with confusing
complex systems and token stylistic
trappings of Japanese RPGs but the sense
of wander that comes from exploring its
vast world the empowerment that comes
from piloting it's transforming bipedal
mechs and the satisfaction of fighting
it's large impressive creatures makes it
one of the best experiences of 2015 on
any platform and when you think about
the Wii U this year the best experiences
of 2015 should be the first thing that
comes to mind
[Music]
you